try to keep your answers short
I don't know how to make that one pal
doc sanitary stated that is a deep three
how does that Lana not know that kyrie
irving's on the floor that kids get
eight here at the quarter
Irving Oh foots the defense with the
dribble I reefs were Vicki anywhere he
walked on the floor and the whole true
bulb is gonna be this fan right here
Kyrie sitting out of the corners of
those triple handoffs and make a
basketball plays from it Kyrie Brown for
three and he knocks it down
go on what he wants to do yeah what do
you really wants to do is play
pick-and-roll just where I thought Kyrie
had nowhere to go on that baseline
Kyrie you going to the baseline now look
at this is pretty good sympathy switch
good Kontest to ground
as it knocked away Kairi picks it off
nice catch by smarts gonna take it bake
it you're right
great catch by smart staying in that
corner I would have passed by Kyrie
passed by Kyrie look at that one-hand
bullet pass it's so good
[Applause]
Souths xfinity ball
Tatom
how about that ball movement by the
Boston Celtics gets the ball splits the
defense kicks it to the corner today to
begin the defense lose the ball but
somehow gets it back wide open and I've
been extremely
I read like a package like a dog in the
park
it really is off the dribble finds
Horford three on the shot clock Irene's
gotta shoot it realizes it
no space knows the crowd long down I got
this here bar goes back to Kyrie low in
the clock left it fly Bazemore in his
face bang Fritos the crowd I got this
but 10 is teammate down to 8
[Applause]
Irving checks the clock gets in the
paint little floater goes Wow running
the clock down I mean there's another
guy coming it's like he doesn't see the
defense